ABCs of AI C is for chat Bots a chatbot
is a computer program that simulates
human conversation through text or voice
they're commonly used to answer customer
support questions but are also often
used for sales marketing and educational
purposes conversational AI used by
chatbots is made possible by natural
language processing a field of AI that
allows computers to understand and
process human language and since
chatbots are built to simulate human
conversations chances are that you've
likely chatted with the chatbot before
and didn't even realize it chatbots have
two main types rule-based chatbots are
programmed with a set of rules that
Define how they should respond to
certain prompts for example an FAQ
chatbot that's programmed specifically
to only answer questions about the
animals hours and location of your local
Zoo while machine learning based
chatbots learn how to respond to prompts
by analyzing large amounts of data for
example an animal facts chat bot trained
on large amounts of encyclopedic data of
all animals all over the world try
having to chat with Google's
conversational AI Bard check out the
links in our description for more info
and to find resources on how to build
your own chat Bots what AI topics do you
want to know more about on the next
episode of